hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast lactate driven metabolic
adaptation modulates breast cancer
progression presented by Jennifer Molina
PhD we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laggards
and sponsored by agilent agilent is a
leader in life sciences clinical
research diagnostics and applied
chemical markets with over 11,000
employees worldwide the company provides
laboratories worldwide with instruments
services consumables applications and
expertise enabling customers to gain the
insights they seek agilent's expertise
and trusted collaboration provide the
highest confidence in its solutions
Agilent focuses its expertise on six key
markets where the company helps its
customers achieve their goals
food environmental and forensics
pharmaceutical Diagnostics chemical and
energy and clinical research for more
information please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor for today's
events this presentation has been
approved for continuing educational
credits if you want to obtain the
credits please click on me get your free
CM ECT credits button located in the
lower left of your screen this will take
you to the continuing education page
where you can select speaker click on
the CEC IME button and it will take you
through the process to obtain your
certification before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
also please note that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right and finally if you have any
trouble seeing hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
you're having a problem thank you now
I'd like to introduce Jennifer Molina
PhD Institute research scientist at the
Institute for applied cancer science at
MD Anderson Cancer Center dr. Molina has
a PhD in biomedical science from the
University of Texas Graduate School of
biomedical science and research
experience in the fields of cancer
biology biochemistry cell signaling and
drug discovery dr. Molina joined the
Institute for applied cancer science I a
CS in 2015 following a postdoctoral
fellowship in the department of systems
biology at MD Anderson Cancer Center
where she focused on uncovering
mechanisms of metabolic adaptation in
breast cancer for the discovery of
potential therapeutic metabolic targets
dr. Molina is an institute research
scientist in the viola biology division
at iacs please join me in welcoming dr.
Molina I will now turn the presentation
over to her the
very much Judy I hope everyone can hear
me and I want to thank adjuvant
technologies and lab groups for the
opportunity to present my work as Judy
mentioned I I finished my postdoctoral
training in systems biology in the
laboratory of gordon mills and the work
I'm presenting today was all done in
during that time and I am about three
months ago I joined I acts also at MD
Anderson and I'm working on a novel
metabolic targets in cancer so for today
the title of the talk is likely driven
metabolic adaptation modulates breast
cancer progression breast cancer is a
devastating disease that affects many
people every year in 2014 alone there
were over 200,000 new cases in females
and over 2000 cases in mail it is a very
heterogeneous disease and extensive
molecular profiling has uncovered that
there are several subtypes of breast
cancer that are characterized by key
genetic mutations and amplifications and
they are highlighted on the left the
subtypes are aluminum which is
characterized by increased expression of
the estrogen and progesterone receptors
her - amplified which is characterized
by amplification in the erbp - gene
there is also a small subtype called the
Claudine loan which is more stem-like in
behavior and then there is the infamous
triple negative breast cancer subtypes
which is has low estrogen and
progesterone receptors and high
expression of other markets like the EGF
receptor and so on and it can also have
increased her - expression these
subtypes also represent different
outcomes in patients and you can see
this on the on the right-hand side and
this graph here expresses of survival
overall so
impatience and as you can see the
luminal subtype in blue has the best
prognosis as compared to the the rest of
them where triple negative subtype and
her two subtypes have the worst outcome
in patients along with the subtypes that
were uncovered in patient samples
analysis of 60 different breast cancer
cell lines and this has been done by
multiple groups all over the world
uncover that the cell lines retained the
same same subtypes as the patient
samples ooh so this makes them valuable
tools to study cancer breast cancer
biology and that's exactly what we have
done because we know that breast cancer
is a very heterogeneous disease
genetically and epigenetically we also
wanted to know if this heterogeneity is
found as far as metabolism and how cells
metabolize the major nutrients glucose
and glutamine and in this graph what I
wanted to show was the workflow of what
we typically do to begin examining like
basal metabolism in breast cancer cells
first of all the two major nutrients in
cancers are glucose and glutamine
glucose can be metabolized to make
pyruvate and then it has multiple faiths
one which is flux through the TCA cycle
and electron transport chain and the
other one is conversion to lactate which
is called the Warburg effect or aerobic
glycolysis in the presence of oxygen the
other nutrient is glutamine which can be
converted to glutamate and either also
feed the TCA cycle or be secreted as
glutamate what will usually perform to
test differences in breast cancer cells
is to take fresh medium and compare it
to spent medium after a certain time
points
and what we can calculate and this was
done by using the whyisign metabolic
analyzer all protocols are found in me
in the citation seeing here we can see
consumption of glucose over time and
production of lactate over time and we
can calculate black of integrations from
this and we can also examine glutamine
consumption and glutamate secretion into
the media and I'll be talking about this
further once we get more into the data
another method that we typically use to
analyze basal metabolic rates in breast
cancer cells is using the XM analyzer by
secret Biosciences this methodology
allows us to look at the oxygen
consumption rates as well as the
extracellular acidification rates which
is typically a measure of lactate
production in cells in real time in this
particular example we use the
mitochondrial stress test which which is
one of the methods that can be used in
this essay the essay allows us first to
interrogate basal metabolic rates so how
much oxygen is consumed by cells and how
much lactate is produced in real time
and then it allows you still allows you
to inject different inhibitors up to
four and see what happens to the okarin
occur in real-time so for in this case
we used four different mitochondrial
inhibitors first we used a little myosin
which is an ATP synthase inhibitor and
you can see a drop in the ocher next was
an FC CP is FC CP which is a nun coupler
that allows electron flow and it shows
the maximal respiratory capacity so how
much cells can compensate during stress
and then finally a complex complex one
and three inhibitors ant amazing and
rotenone which completely kill okar and
then allows you to to calculate the
spare capacity so here I'm just
illustrating two different cell lines as
you can see the basal metabolic rates
are different in the two and you can
also get differences in after in maximal
respiratory capacity and these are also
you're able to correlate with responses
in the extracellular as in acidification
rates and finally that allows you to
calculate the amount of oxygen that is
consumed to generate ATP for ATP
production so we apply this type of
exercise in a panel of breast cancer
cells and to our surprise we found that
if we looked at compared basal or triple
negative which are in black and we
compared them to the luminal subtype
which are here in red and this is a car
ATP over eco the ratio we found that the
luminal subtypes tended to be more
oxidative and the basal subtypes tended
to be more glycolytic next we correlated
these differences looking looking at
gene expression in in different subtypes
and we found that actually a lot of the
major metabolic enzymes were
differentially expressed and there was a
dichotomous expression
and a lot of these enzymes are
responsible for different types of
metabolism so some of the most
significantly differentially expressed
genes are involved in lactic transport
and metabolism so the number one
dichotomous expressed gene in breast
cancer that we were able to identify is
LD HP the lactate dehydrogenase B
isoform this is enzyme that can convert
pyruvate to lactate in addition to that
the two transporters of lactate which
are here SOC 69 1 and 3 or MC t1 MC t
floor were also dichotomously expressed
so some cells are very high level some
cells had very low levels of these
enzymes of these genes and that also
translated to protein levels and finally
at p p1 and as you can see this
differential expression is significant
because here are the estrogen receptor
and the her2 gene which are used to
subtype and and clinically select the
treatment in patients so if we compare
the differential expression of some of
these metabolic genes as compared to
what is use diagnostically it is
significant so this part are interesting
back to biology in breast cancer and we
continued looking at what can be going
on with lactate biology when we look at
patient data on the on the Left we can
see this is survival of patients within
the triple negative subtype of breast
cancer that have high levels of MC t1
the lactic transporter we see that
survival is significantly lower than
patients that have low logic
transporters and this also translated to
the expression levels of MMC t1 and this
data was analyzed for from the TCGA
database cited here other studies of all
so associated that high lactate was
found to be highlighted in patients in
clinical samples was associated with
chemotherapy and radiotherapy resistance
immune system evasion high angiogenesis
in tumors and increased metastasis and
on the right is an example here where
samples were examined from human cervix
cervical cancer and those tumors that
had highlighted in remember
microenvironment had worse survival in
addition to that recent publications
have shown that there is heterogeneity
in the Preferences of nutrients that
different cells that make up tumors
consume some cells are varied some tumor
cells and areas are very glycolytic
while others prefer glutamine
consumption or lipid consumption one
particular study showed that there is an
inverse correlation in the level of
lactate in tumors where where lactate is
high in tumors glucose send it to be
lower and vice versa and that also
correlated with ATP levels so this this
and other studies influenced our our
curiosity to study what lactate can
provide cells during nutrient stress
when glucose or blue timing levels are
low and and perhaps that could play a
role in the survival so this was our
original hypothesis that when breast
cancer cells have plenty of glucose they
can metabolize glucose to make pyruvate
and then eventually to make lagdi
lactate accumulates in the micro
environment as has been shown by many
different studies and the cells can also
metal
I liked pyruvate from glucose to through
the TCA cycle to make plenty of ATP
however there are many studies showing
that cancer cells have tend to have a
preference for like Allah sees or lactic
production which makes very little ATP
as compared to full oxidation through
the TCA cycle so we wonder why is this
it seems like a wasteful mechanism that
throws out perfectly good carbons
into the microenvironment so we
hypothesize that lactate accumulates but
in areas where glucose is low as
compared to areas when glucose is high
both glucose and Reutimann are low cells
are under nutrient stress and perhaps
they could utilize the lock day that
accumulates in the micro environment
which is plentiful I can go up to about
10 millimolar as compared to
physiological which is only 1 millimolar
and feed feed cells during times of
neutral stress so cells could could make
whatever they need to survive ok so we
wondered if this was happening and what
pathways could be utilized by lactate
metabolism under nutrient stress
conditions so to interrogate this in
terms of a screen in many different
breast cancer cell lines we chose just
very simple conditions to compare and to
see look at survival so we chose a
physiological media condition which
contained physiologically relevant
levels of glucose glutamine or lactate
which is 5.5 and 1 millimolar
respectively compared it to a base
medium without the 3 nutrients which we
termed nutrient free and it's a negative
control and then we compare that to a
highlighted condition of 10 millimolar
lactate which is typically found
breast tumors and we analyze induction
of apoptosis in the different conditions
after treatment and then we did a number
of other assays and I'll go over all
these data subsequently so during our
screen we looked at percent survival in
physiological and as you can see we had
a hundred percent survival overall while
in nutrient free conditions we had 20
out of 20 for breast cancer cells that
died which was expected and then when we
added high lactate to that nutrient free
media we found that most of the sullens
received some significant benefit from
having latin in the media basically
there was a delay in the apoptosis for
these cells but most strikingly was at
seven out of those 24 cell lines and
these are highlighted in red were really
lacking sufficient cells they survived
very efficiently in highlighted alone
and if we looked at the subtypes of
these cells we really didn't see we saw
an arrangement in the basilar
triple-negative subtype as far as
surviving but we also saw a few that
survived in the luminal subtype and one
her to positive so for the more
mechanistic studies we chose two cell
lines to compare and we chose mcf 10a
cells which are derived from normal
breast epithelium and we also chose the
HTC 19:37 cells which are based on
triple negative cells to do further
studies well so this is a measure of
percent viable cells by exclusion of
apoptotic cells in the presence of other
physiological media which of course we
see survival over over four days
nurturing 3 we see rapid and so
that and highlighted there is a
significant maintenance of survival even
at after four days in high lactate media
and if we compare that to the MCF to
nacelles we see that there is a
significant difference in the number of
cells surviving this was also consistent
with the morphology the maintenance of
morphology and size in ACC 1937 cells
which are the elastic sufficient cells
versus the normal cells and so the next
kind of obvious place to look was energy
and redox balance so we started looking
at a and P two ATP ratios in both
conditions and found that there was a
maintenance of ATP in both HCC 19:37
cells as well as there empty of teeny
cells
so this told us that lactate is
providing ATP even in the less efficient
lactic sufficient cells so ATP
maintenance is not part of the full
story here but it certainly plays a role
next we looked at nad to NADH ratios and
found the same maintenance of NADH in
both the last its efficient and the
latter insufficient cells which tells us
that again this is part of the story but
not the full mechanism and then finally
we looked at oxygen consumption by the
seahorse XL analyzer and found
significant increase very significant
increases in the oxygen consumption when
lactate is present in the HCC 19:37
cells and only minor oxygen consumption
increase in the other cell line so this
told us that perhaps we should be
looking at lactate being converted to
pyruvate which can be metabolized into
the TCA cycle for NADH production and
then taken into the electron transport
chain
for ATP production finally by using the
Wi-Fi analyzer as I was previously
talking about analyzing lactate levels
in the media we confirm that in fact
when lotted is present at high levels it
is consumed by the cells involved the
MCF tane and HCC 1937 cells
so to summarize part one we found that
cells deeply lack the exogenous lactate
from the media this promoted survival
help to maintain ATP nadh levels and
increase the oxygen consumption so next
we wanted to know the mechanism of what
else is helping cells to survive when
latter is present so for that we did we
use three different methods first we
used labeled carbon 13 labeled lactate
fully labeled lactate to do mass
spectrometry analysis as well as NMR
analysis but then our main experiment
was really to to look in an unbiased way
to do metabolomics analysis in the
presence of latte in in the HCC 1937
cells to see what what could be
happening there so this is the workflow
that we used to analyze the our cells
so after sample preparation we compared
high lactate cells grown in highlighted
media versus nutrients stress condition
we did the examination by lcms analysis
using the adenine 6550 I finally of LCMS
in with a hillock column a hillock
chromatography the chromatogram
alignment was done by mass feature
extraction using the mass hunter pro
finder software
statistical analysis was done to
identify the most significantly changed
metabolites and then the mass profiler
professional software was used to
identify the what these metabolites are
and this work was done in collaboration
with Agilent thoughts leader scientists
as well as Peter malarkey here at i/o at
MD Anderson here are the results of our
unbiased screen 280 features were
extracted with pro finder 86 were
significantly different between the two
conditions and about 50% were annotating
annotated with the Matlin database and
as you can see there overall heat map
where nutrient freeze on the left and
lots it is on the right you can see that
there are significant differences in
several metabolites and I'll get into
the specifics here so overall when
locked it was presence we saw that
several TCA cycle components were
increased and they are here oxaloacetate
sister chromatid Sassanid fumarate and
Mallett where increases compared to
nutrient free media several amino acids
were also increased including glutamine
and glutamate and several nucleotides
were increased as well as a few my
policies as well as pyruvate I'm sorry
primarily so this gave us an idea of
where to work specifically within the
different carbon central carbon
metabolism pathways so we moved forward
to do NMR analysis with fully labeled
lactate to see where specifically the
carbons from lactate were found and here
is the overall picture so on the top is
the HTC 19:37 cells and at the bottom we
have the normal and CF 10a self and
the main the main difference here is
that the ACC 1937 cells were really able
to produce a lot of different
metabolites as compared to them CFD
nacelles so the main the main amino
acids that were found to be enriched
with lactate carbons are glutamine
glutamate alanine aspartate and glycine
this world made in delegates efficient
cells while in the lab the insufficient
cells that the main amino acids were
only glutamine and glutamate in addition
to that we saw that there is a big
enrichment and flow of carbon of lotta
carbons in through many different cycles
in the TCA of the TCA cycle which
produce specific label patterns in the
glutamine glutamate so after round one
we see this pattern and after several
rounds there's a saturation of the
signal another very important point that
we observed was that oxaloacetate or
aspartate which comes from us
oxaloacetate had different signaling
carbon patterns so that told us that one
one of the versions of excel off of
sparked aid is coming from oxaloacetate
that comes from the TCA cycle but
another one is actually coming from a
direct reaction coming from pyruvate
oxaloacetate compression and this is
done by pyruvate carboxylase enzyme
finally when we looked at the patterns
of labeling in glycine that also
correlated to God gave us a hint that
perhaps we should be looking at
gluconeogenesis or reverse psychology's
because glycine comes from the serine
pathway arm of
policies and in this case we don't have
any glucose in the in the environment in
the media but I'll get into the
specifics of that a bit later okay
so because we know that robust electron
transport chain oxidative
phosphorylation is also related to
production of high levels of reactive
oxygen species that's toxic to cells we
also look at the major antioxidant in
cells which is glutathione since we
observed that cells can make glutamate
and glycine from lactaid and these two
are components of glutathione and are
used in it's simply the novo synthesis
of glutathione we thought okay maybe the
cells can take this amino acids they
make from that day to make it a thiamine
to relieve some of reactive oxygen
species that they are producing from
oxfords
so we looked at this in many different
ways first we looked at levels of
hydrogen peroxide and we found that
lotted maintained lower levels of
hydrogen peroxide in HCC 1937 cells
while in MCFC nacelles first of all
levels were higher to begin with but
they were not maintained or decreased in
the presence of Lotte next we look at we
looked at NADPH production which is also
necessary to deplete rostrum cells and
we found that NADPH is maintained in the
presence of lot aid in HCC 1937 cells
where while it is lost in MCFC nacelles
even when water is present and then
finally we used we looked at levels of
gluten reduced butit ion in by using
carbon 13 labeled lactate
again in HTC 19 tourism cells and found
that there there is enrichment of
carbons coming from Latin in reduce to
define this tells us that cells were
utilizing the carbons from black day to
make glutamate and glycine that can
become de novo glutathione and that was
again helping for survival and as a
proof of concept we use BSO which is an
inhibitor of the synthesis of
glutathione and every time that we did
this in many different cells when we
treat ourselves with be a soul we saw a
significant decrease in the survival of
cells in black tea and this was rescued
by the addition of glutathione so
together all this data tells us that
there is no synthesis of glutathione
from Latin metabolism and that is
required as part of the survival under
nutrient stress and that increased
reducing power is associated with lower
survival and that's the that is a
mechanism one of the mechanisms we found
that Latin is helping with in during new
distress okay so next we wanted to
interrogate how cells could possibly be
making serum and/or glycine when they
only have lotted presence so in this
pathway we can see glycolysis and at the
3pg branch is where the serine producing
pathway is found and that leads to also
glycine production so we hypothesize
that cells could perhaps be taking
lactate metabolizing it through the TCA
cycle to make oxaloacetate on aspartate
and then that aspartate will in turn be
reconverted to oxaloacetate in the
cytoplasm and be converted to
phosphoenolpyruvate
which is a second step of reverse
psychology's and the cells could carry
on the pathway backwards to make 3pg and
that would lead to glycine production
the next question we also had was if in
fat cells were able to do this reverse
psychologists from far up the pathway
they could be going if perhaps they were
able to go all the way up to the pentose
phosphate pathway which is a major
product production of NADPH which is
needed to maintain reduce levels of
glutathione to combat toxicity of
reactive oxygen species as well as
eventual production of nucleotides so
the way we looked at this was to
interrogate the first two steps in
reverse psychology's first we did we
knocked down pyruvate carboxylase which
is the converts pyruvate to oxaloacetate
and after knockdown of PC we observed a
significant decrease in the survival of
HCC 1937 cells but this actually was
rescued by addition of glutamine to
lactate and that makes make sense
because glutamine can be converted to
glutamate and enter the TCA cycle as
alpha ketoglutarate and can provide the
oxaloacetate needed to circumvent this
problem so cells could actually make
aspartate from that oxaloacetate derived
from the Doudna mean so that rescued
aligns with what with what we know next
we also
looked at the second step of reverse
psychology's which is conversion of
oxaloacetate to phosphoenolpyruvate and
we did this by treating cells with the
drug drug little zine took with ozone
and found that there was a very very
robust decrease in the survival of cells
in the presence of lactate when PC k1 is
a PC k1 inhibitor when we treat the
cells with this however this time asks
us as we would expect we didn't see any
rescue with the addition of either
glutamine or glutamate and that also
made sense with what we know about these
pathways because cells even if they can
undergo on a pluralist from glutamine
are made to make a Spartan and
oxaloacetate they would not be able to
convert it to phosphoenolpyruvate so
this was a first hint that reverse
psychology's may be involved in the
metabolism of latte and impacted we know
from normal physiology that live in the
liver there is metabolism of lactate to
make eagles so the next step here was to
really look at some of the components of
this pathway of reverse psychology's and
pentose phosphate pathway and serine
pathway by doing mass spectrometry with
carbon 13 labeled lactate and we found
that in all cases we found that carbon
13 carbons coming from lactate were
found in searing first of all so that
confirms why glycine was produced also
we found label in g6p which tells us
that cells were able to metabolize
carbons from lactate all the way up to
the pentose phosphate pathway in
addition to that we also found label in
several different nucleotides like our
first backbones of nucleotides are 5p i
MP ADP ATP nad and NADP these are all
backbones of purine nucleotides and then
when we inhibited g6pd by tree which is
the first step in the pentose phosphate
pathway it's an inhibitor of objects SPD
DHEA we saw a robust decrease in the
survival of cells
groaning lactate so it tell it tells us
that part of the mechanism which is
required for survival under under
lactate metabolism is the ability for
cells to metabolize carbons through the
pentose phosphate pathway so in order to
to see if we could apply this mechanism
as part of the what we know in breast
cancer we chose to analyze combinations
with with two different inhibitors first
we thought okay we could induce
nutrients stress by treating cells with
two deoxy glucose which is a glycolysis
inhibitor it competes with normal
glucose and cells retain that they
cannot undergo glycolysis past the first
step of glycolysis so in the first
scenario that we could think of if we
would treat cells with 2dg alone and
they are lactate sufficient cells they
should be able to compensate by
metabolizing lactate with the pathways
that I just described and undergo
reverse lipolysis to to make to run the
pentose phosphate or the serine and
glycine producing pathways and TCA cycle
this should not be in theory very toxic
to cells on the other hand if we treat
with drop leaders in alone and and this
is of course under physiological
conditions when cells have Google's the
cells are not dependent on reverse
psychology's in this case so inhibiting
that pck one would not should not be
very toxic to cells either but if we
combine the two so we make the cells we
can make the cells dependent on lactate
metabolism after 2dg treatment and then
blocking pck would prevent them from
metabolizing lat lactate through the
reverse psychology's and in theory there
should be an additive effect between the
two between a combination so we started
this with just cell lines and this is a
htc 1937 cell looking at survival first
under high levels of glucose so
physiological levels of glucose which is
5 milli molar and we our reasoning
behind this was that normal cells have
physiological levels of media as
compared to tumors that are where Lata
is high glucose would be low so this is
why we chose this condition so under
physiological conditions a normal cell
would not would not suffer the toxic
toxicity levels achieved with the
combination of these two compounds under
nutrient stress conditions however when
there is no googles both the combination
and table design alone were able to
really decrease viability substantially
and then in in areas in a tumor where
glucose is low in that it is high
treatment with the single agents alone
did not have any effect however the
combination
was very effective at decreasing at
killing cells and we were able to repeat
this in several other lines with the
same additive effect between induction
of nutrients stress by inhibition
psychologist and then inhibition of pck
by treatment with with ozone and we did
this in a total of four different
lactate sufficient lines which are here
the also MDA and B 468 which is a triple
negative line
SKB r3 which is a her two amplified line
and camel one which is aluminum line
there were a few differences in in the
potency of triplet ozone in a few lines
and that correlated with the actual mRNA
levels of PC k1 so that could be a hint
that for for that in that particular
case we would need two hits physically
one harder and then this was a the most
interesting part after the after this
experiment was done I took the remaining
cells in in the dish and just removed
the drug and replenished fresh for which
cell culture media and waited to see
what cells came back and in in all cases
the combination between two DG
interpreters own did not have any cells
coming back and and and restarting in
proliferation so there were no survival
surviving cells after driving along
while the single treatments did not have
the same effect and then finally we we
analyzed these effects in vivo in an
orthotopic xenograph the model with the
HCC 19:37 cells and as you can see there
is
an additive effect in tumor growth over
time although we didn't quite see any
quite see a regression we saw a
cytostatic effect or maintenance of a
low tumor size as compared to the single
treatments alone or vehicle and the main
point was that whatever grew the tumor
sizes remained quite small as compared
to the single treating tumors this could
be because there is you know I think
this speaks to the fact that if we are
really thinking that this combination
especially targeting PC k4 lactate
dependent tumors we would benefit from
using a more potent inhibitor of PC K so
this is just to summarize the mechanisms
that so far we've we've uncovered and
others as well
lactate is converted to pyruvate and
metabolized in cells for continuous
rounds of the TCA cycle ox false
generates both ATP nadh as well as ross
reactive oxygen species these are toxic
to cells so that probably signal cells
to start producing some amino acids and
what we found so far is that cells may
loosen a determinist part eight searing
lies in an alanine all from lactate and
with those amino acids they they were
able to synthesize glutathione maintain
rose levels low and by employing reverse
psychologists they made additional amino
acids some which are required to make
Goods of science they increase or
maintain levels of NADPH and they were
able to make purine nucleotides all for
survival
so here are some of the lessons learned
and that we can apply lactate in this
case based on these mechanisms may
present a roadblock for targeting
metabolic enzymes by enabling resistance
and I say this because the cells were
able to make many different amino acids
and nucleotides from lactate so
targeting certain metabolic enzymes in
the presence of highlighted my
compensate by actually making the the
products or metabolites that you are
trying to inhibit one of which can be
production of glutamate which we're now
is under study by many different groups
so a potential application or
intervention strategy for latter biology
could be that induction of nutrients
stress perhaps by glycolysis inhibition
could could be a an arena in which you
create lot a dependent subpopulations
that emerge and that you can target by
inhibiting one of the enzymes that cells
become dependent on when they are using
that they'd like PCG so it would be
interesting to work with better
compounds to physically to understanding
this is feasible or not and with that
I'd just like to acknowledge everybody
that I've worked on on this team so like
I said this work was done in the
laboratory of gordon mills I don't
understand cancer center department and
systems biology these were all my my
collaborators in the lab we said listed
here I'd also like to acknowledge the
CCG CCSD characterization but Selangor
all the mass spectrometry and NMR work
was done by Pietro Maliki in
collaboration with Agilent leader
scientists and also the NMR
was done in collaboration with Kumar
choleric Karachi and I also worked with
Lesley Silva for some mass spectrometry
analysis so thank you very much for
your attention and I guess now we can
move to some questions yes thank you dr.
Molina for that informative presentation
it is time for Q&A so if you have a
question you'd like to ask dr. Molina
please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is how
general do you think this mechanism of
lactate metabolism is across various
cancer types oh yes so yes so I think it
can be very applicable because as we
know most cancers especially solid
cancers are now being detected by
fdg-pet scan and that is essentially a
measure of like Allah sees so glycolytic
tumors light up and that's how they are
detected and you can we know that
glycolysis means lactate production
however the actual application of
targeting lactate is not going to be as
a single single agent treatment I think
it should be in explore with greater
detail in the context of nutrients
stress so if you were to target lactate
alone you're going to hit a sub
population themselves in tumors that are
under nutrient stress characterizing
what population that is would be
interesting but then also thinking about
combinations with maybe standard of care
or other methodologies like targeted
therapies would be interesting to
explore I so I think that there's a lot
of work to be done there have been some
hints about targeting the transport the
import of lactate into cells there's
work there by several groups showing
that for some cancer types
it can it can have some effect but I
think it's still too early to tell how
general this can be why the focus on
measuring metabolites can you repeat
that and why the I'll just repeat that
question why the focus on measuring
metabolites so the focus that focus on
measuring metabolites for this
particular case I was very important
because for example if we had only
looked at protein expression or gene
expression that could have told us some
changes in different in the levels of
different enzymes that might be changing
for example you know we originally we
looked at mRNA levels of the different
enzymes but that doesn't really tell us
what is going on in the cells I think
interrogating the levels of metabolites
across different conditions can really
tell us what the cells are doing as far
as metabolizing the major nutrients like
glucose and glutamine so that we can
assess much better what in terms of
cancer and targeting what the pathways
that are being utilized by different
cancer types
knowing the levels of the metabolites is
essential in really figuring out how the
cells are surviving and proliferating
and what they are using the different
sources to make so if we we have found
that lactate was not just used to make
ATP I think that that was just part of
the question if we had not looked at
more than that we
never we would never have uncovered all
the other amino acids and the
nucleotides
what about iymp so i am p we found
lactate carbons in our mass spectrometry
labeled lactate experiment we did find
that i NP was labeled from latin and we
think that it's it was from the flux
through the pentose phosphate pathway we
found our 5 p and diane p labeled and we
also found other nucleotide so i think i
summarized nad and ATP ATP adp as well
as our 5 p and when we inhibited the
pentose phosphate pathway by treatment
with DHEA we saw a decrease in the
survival of cells i did not try to
rescue the effects of inhibition with
any nucleotides but that's something
that i could try to do i know that there
were recent publications i think within
the last month let's show the importance
of ox falls and electron transport chain
in the production of nucleotides via the
production of aspartate so i think that
that's certainly a mechanism that's
tying in to this story that you know
lactate provides aspartate that's us
need to make nucleotides and they're
left on transport chain and oxford is
certainly something that latter is
contributing to for that purpose what
genomic mutations or gene expression
changes are associated with lactate
sufficiency
yes so as far as genomic mutations I'm
not really sure but as far as expression
gene expression levels I would I would
say that the cells that tend to have
higher gene expression levels of the
likely transporters like MC t1 and city
4 as well as higher levels of gene
expression levels of the lactic
dehydrogenase enzymes LDH a and B are
are found to be lactate sufficient
furthermore in in our project we also
looked at levels of the enzymes involved
in gluconeogenesis so FB p1 was
associated with lactates efficiency as
well as p ck and pc levels of pyruvate
carboxylase and fossil Anil pyruvate
carboxylase all of those were associated
with sufficiency with lactate the next
one is a two parter have you looked at
cancer cell lines of other types and
what about prostate cancer so the next
question was if I've looked at cancer
cell lines of other types
what about prostate cancer and I think I
haven't I have not personally done this
work but I think there is work that has
been done in prostate cancer where they
have found that lactate maintained
viability and survival in prostate
cancer cells
in the slide in which you show the
increase of different compounds in cells
incubated in the presence absence of
lactate you didn't comment what happens
to new nucleotides can you give us some
information about in particular
regarding InP okay next question I think
I have a partial question here but it's
talking about the increase of different
compounds in cells incubated in the
presence of lactate but I'm sorry I'm
not it Oh
in the presence of lactate I didn't
comment what happens to the nucleotides
okay I think I it's talking again about
I MP I think I answered all I know about
I am P at this point was that we found
carbons coming from that they enriched
in I MP the percentage was not huge but
it was they're targeting lactate
metabolism in breast cancer could alter
calcium levels and release from the
endoplasmic reticulum that's right
that's a question or a comment so if you
have a thought share please do try
reading okay so the question is
targeting Latin metabolism in breast
cancer it could alter can could alter
cause calcium levels and release from
the ER I haven't looked at calcium
levels I'll tell you that the death that
I am seeing is apoptosis I didn't so and
the way I know that is because I all my
viability assets that I show to show
percent survival
our labeling with di oc6
as well as propidium iodide however I
didn't dive into all the different types
of apoptosis but I know for sure that it
is apoptosis but I have not looked at
calcium levels we're almost out of time
so this will have to be our last
question is there any known correlation
between psychological stress and tissue
cellular stress and a second part
reverse psychosis is glutathione
production with a high own production
okay so for the for the first part of
the question is talking about it's
asking about a correlation between
psychological stress and tissue cellular
stress I am NOT an expert in
psychological psychological stress so
I'm not I'm afraid I cannot comment on
that I'm wondering if that was
physiological stress instead of
psychological stress I'm not sure if
we're talking about physiological stress
as far as levels of decreased decrease
glucose and glutamine that will that
should have an impact on the metabolism
cause nutrient stress and therefore
cellular stress and lactate was we have
showing we and others are showing that
lots it is a compensatory can be a
compensatory mechanism because it's
allowing cells to make some of the
biomass molecules they need to survive
and then the second part of the question
is is reverse psychology school defiant
production so reverse electrolysis
is essentially gluconeogenesis is
basically when cells move through floods
through the glycolysis pathway backwards
and in for example liver cells they do
this and the glucose they may can also
be stored as glycogen in our case with
find flux all the way to regular glucose
but we did find that cells were
producing going through glycolysis to
produce first serine and then glycine
glycine is required for the noble
synthesis of glutathione is a tripeptide
that contains glutamate cysteine and
glycine so what date was able to provide
carbons to make two out of the three
amino acids that make up meeteth ion and
when we looked at labeled carbons coming
from Lockheed in glutathione we found
significant percent of the design was
labeled from that eight carbons so it
contributed for that production of the
design I would like to once again thank
dr. Molina for her presentation do you
have any final comments dr. Molina just
want to thank everyone I just want to
thank everyone for your attention for
all your great questions if you want to
communicate with me in the future I am
on LinkedIn so please find me I'd be
happy to answer all the questions you
have and maybe set up some
collaborations and maybe I'll have some
questions myself for you in all of your
research that you do so thank you so
much this was a wonderful experience
thank you to adjoin technologies and lab
roots for this opportunity thank you
attendees should check back later for a
PDF of this presentation and literature
on cancer metabolics is available at the
Agilent booth and you may go there to
further speak with experts head over to
the Agilent booth just reminder if you
wish to obtain the credits for today's
session please click on me get your free
cm ECE credits button located in the
lower left of your screen this will take
you to the continuing education page
where you can select a speaker click on
the CEC M
button guided through the process to
obtain your certification before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing for six months from today's live
event you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us see you again soon
goodbye